The last three companies I founded and
sold grew so fast it felt illegal. Used
Allen got to $1.2 million per month at
the end of the first year. Prestige Labs
got to $1.5 million per month by the end
of the first year. And Gym Launch got
over $2 million per month by the end of
the first year. I'm going to show you
the strongest growth levers I used to
get these results so that you can, too.
Let's start with the first one, which is
nobody knows you exist.
And if you're under $1 million in
revenue, I can virtually guarantee you
that basically everyone on Earth doesn't
know you exist. And so, the first 4
hours of every day should be dedicated
to solving that problem and going from
obscurity to being aware. And so, we do
that by doing the core four more, which
is you have to do more outreach, cold or
warm. You have to make more content, or
you got to run ads. But the thing is is
you don't need to do all of them. You
pick one, you go all in, and that's what
you spend your first 4 hours every
single day on. Now, the reason that I
talk about advertising more so much is
that advertising is a boom. And if
you're like, "What's a boom?" It's
actually a term that I started using
internally for our business, which is a
business order of magnitude change. All
right? And so, fundamentally, if you
think about a business, there are many
things that you can optimize. So, you
can increase your close rate by 10%. You
can increase your your conversion rate
on your on your opt-in page by 10%. You
can increase your email follow-up. All
of those things are optimizations. And
so, the problem is with optimizations,
you can only go to 100%. They're capped.
But with advertising, you can, in a very
real way, 100x the amount of people who
find out about your business. And one of
the keys that small business owners get
stuck in is they get in this little
optimization mouse trap, where they're
like, "I need to move this. Oh, I I I I
I was at 10.1 one to one, and now I need
to be at at 10.2 to one." It's like,
"Dude, just get 100 times the leads, and
your business will grow." So, here's
what most people think when they think
about their given marketplace. So, let's
say you're a local dry cleaner. All
right? You see that you're advertising
on Facebook. And so, you see you have
the whole pie, and so you're happy. So,
that's just you. Then, you have you plus
one other person. Then all of a sudden,
you've got half of the pie. Then it's
you plus three other people in the
marketplace. And now, you feel sad.
But, the reality is the marketplace is
significantly bigger than you ever give
it credit for. There are so many humans
on Earth. This is what it looks like in
reality. You're actually only
advertising on one of four different
methods, and the way that you're doing
it is only on one slice of the medium.
And then within that, you have your tiny
little quarter that you are taking up.
And so, the marketplace has so many
different ways they can communicate
using each of the methods of
communication. So, for example, if I'm
talking about content, I'm like, "Oh,
there's somebody else in my marketplace
who's marketing on Instagram." Okay,
cool. So, there's that, but isn't there
also other platforms you can do it on?
And don't you think that maybe there's
enough people in your marketplace to
satisfy your business? Probably. The
amount of times that I would have a gym
owner, for example, who'd come to me and
say, "Hey, there's this other guy in the
marketplace who's now running Facebook
ads." I'm like, "You only need 200
people in your gym to be incredibly
profitable. And right now, last time I
checked, you've got a 1 million people
in your city. And so, you just have to
get 200 of them. And so, if there's 10
others or 100 other gyms that are
advertising your area, even on the same
platform, you still just need to get
0.00002%
of that audience to just come to you.
And so, you think that as these people
enter, you're losing market share, but
the reality is you're this tiny little
speck, and most people don't even know
you exist. So, the next growth principle
is instead of trying to beat your
competition, shrink your competition.
Eminem has responded to hate in two ways
publicly that I absolutely love. So, the
first is that when Will Ferrell
confronted him about some things that
Afrojack had said to him, he said, "Hey,
Afrojack's been talking trash. Do you
have anything to say about it?" And
Eminem just said, "Who?" And then Will
Ferrell repeated the statement. And then
he just looked at him and he was like,
"Who?" And he was like, "Okay, yep,
that's what I thought." And so, the
first is I'm so big I can't hear him.
The secondary is that you kill them with
kindness, right? So, you either grow so
big that no one can see them or hear
them, or you meet them where they're at
on a different game, which is you play
on kindness and grace. And so, in 8
Mile,
Eminem tries to claim all of the flaws
that he has so that no one else can say
anything. And so, I get hit on a lot.
Not like that.
For talking about working a lot, people
are like, "That's not healthy." And of
course, I try to put disclaimers in
every video. I'm like, "Do whatever you
want." Right?
I get hit on for like, "Oh, I think he's
he's trying to make money." Duh. I try
to say it all the time, but people
assume that I am trying to hide this
from others. Of course, I'm trying to
make money. I'm in business. That's the
whole point I do this. And that way, if
I always start with I'm here to make
money, when I do something nice, then
people are like, "Oh, well, that was
nice of him." Rather than me claiming
that I I have to be the super kind
whatever person, and then when I try and
make money, people are like, "Ah." Shake
their finger at me. Like, it's not good.
And so, I try and learn from Eminem and
just take all of the negatives that I
can think that somebody would possibly
say, and then just claim them as my own.
Because, yes, we are all flawed, and
none of us are perfect. And so, for some
reason, we are bothered when someone
else points out our imperfections that
we would readily state ourselves. We
know we have deficiencies. What you want
to do is overwhelm the marketplace so
that you drown them out. You want to be
so loud that no one else can hear them.
You shrink them into irrelevance by
comparison. And so, there's two ways
that you can become the tallest
building, right? You can knock everyone
else down, or you grow so that they
become smaller in comparison to you. And
so, everyone sees their little building
and thinks, "Oh, no, I should knock all
my competitors down." Right? When in
reality, all you need to do is build the
biggest absolute building there. And the
thing is is that you're going to block
out the sun, and your shadow will be so
big that no one can even see these
people. And let me tell you a story
about this.
When I launched my last book, 100
Million Dollar Leads,
I spent a tremendous amount of time and
effort across I think at the time we had
seven-ish million
subscribers or you know audience size
across all platforms. I emailed a bunch,
I made a ton of content, we spent money
on ads, we did outreach, we had
affiliates going, we had all these
different channels going to get as many
people as possible to the launch. And
when I walk around Las Vegas because I
live here, I will usually get stopped
about three-ish times when I do about a
60-minute walk.
Mind you, I walk in a crowded area so
it's not like I'm just like walking in
the neighborhood cuz then that would
just be weird. Anyways, and of course
you should be recognized by your
neighbors. But I'll get stopped by three
people and every time for the month
leading up to the launch, I would be
like, "Hey, you going to the book
launch?" 19 times out of 20, the people
would look at me and be like, "What's
the book launch?" And I was like, "How
do you not know about this, right?" But
it was this wonderful reminder that most
people, when you get tired of your
advertising, most people don't even know
your first name. If you have deluded
yourself into thinking that you should
only have to say something once and
somehow everyone in the entire world has
heard you say that thing, you are
kidding yourself. You need to become a
master of variety in terms of how you
can resay the same thing in different
ways. And taking the natural extreme,
there's this fallacy that most small
business owners think and myself
included for years I thought this was
that repetition in and of itself is
somehow bad. So let me explain.
There's probably people on the internet.
I personally follow a bunch of
philosophy accounts. And so most of the
philosophers are dead. And yet I still
love to see the quotes they have because
they remind me of the things that I want
to follow, the way that I want to live.
And it's not like, "Oh, another Seneca
quote. Does this guy never give up?"
It's like he's dead. He hasn't come up
with a new quote in 2,000 years. And yet
I still like seeing the quotes even
though I know I've seen them before. And
often times you serve that role for your
audience more than anything else. Like,
we think that it's like, "Oh, I've said
this one thing. Therefore, they have all
changed all their behavior immediately
and they never need to learn that
again." But, the biggest lesson that I
have learned is that people need to be
more reminded than they need to be
taught. And in the off chance that
you've received hate or you have a
competitor who's talking crap, and it
happens,
this counts double. So, instead of
trying to beat them or prove them wrong,
you only have two options. Option one is
you grow so big that no one can even
hear them. The alternative is that you
kill them with kindness, which is that
you do not beat them by proving that you
are right.
You beat them by proving that you are
kind.
And then by comparison, they will look
bad.
And so, I can only thing I can tell you
about having dealt with plenty of it in
my day is that on the occasion that I do
choose to respond to hate, I try to
respond with kindness. And so, someone
can just absolutely tear me one to say
like, "This guy sucks. He's terrible.
Whatever." Right? I will then usually
say, "Hey, you're right. I'm a super
flawed person. Um that being said, it
seems like you've developed like a big
audience here and they seem to like you.
And so, congrats on your success."
Right? When someone sees that, it's very
hard for everyone to be like, "Man, that
guy sucks." It's just like now, if I
were to try and like list out all the
points, all I do is invite more back and
forth, which I don't want to do and it's
a waste of my time. And so, instead, you
start all hate responses with you are
right because it's all they want to
hear. And there's really nothing else to
say after that. And so, what's
interesting is that often times hate, if
you boil it down, comes down to I
do not prefer the way this person does
things.
I have a different preference. And it's
like, "Great."
Right? Like, I I make money one way. He
makes money another way. And therefore,
he is wrong. It's like, "No, you just do
the way you want, which is awesome
because you do your way and they do it
their way and the people who are
attracted to that will do that and the
people attracted to you will do yours
and great. Like, I mean, of course,
there's engagement baiting and things
like that because, you know, people
people want to get views and all that
and I and I and I respect it. I get it.
Um but but big picture, I think you
can't take it
um
you can't take it personally because
whenever I I fall into that little trap,
I think to myself, "I'm a relatively
developed monkey that is sitting on a
little blue marble in a solar system
that's in one of a billion galaxies and
I'm worried about some screen that has
words on it on a made-up language that
we had in the last 1,500 years of how we
communicate face noise to each other."
And when I think about that, I think,
you know, this would be pretty silly for
me to like ruin a day over. So, the
third big growth lever, and this one's
massive, is clear, not clever. All
right, so what I mean by that? Well,
when I looked at the highest converting
ads that I had run, and I do this pretty
regularly, I look for different
components. Sometimes I'm like, what's
the hook? Sometimes I'm like, what's the
color scheme? What's the What's the
visuals that are being displayed in the
first however many seconds? And in this
one particular pass, I just looked at
the grade level of the language that was
being spoken. And the reason I looked at
that, it was I think it was a you know,
one or two election cycles ago, I'd
heard this research study that had
stated that the president who spoke in
the lowest grade language was the one
that won the election over and over
again. And when I heard that, I see
presidential elections fundamentally as
massive brand campaigns. And so,
I see that as
they were able to communicate a message
to a higher percentage of the population
because they lowered the barrier to
entry of comprehension. Meaning, more
people got what they said.
And so, when I hear that, I thought,
"Man, I like to use all these big fancy
college words and no one knows what I'm
saying. And so, all I do is feed my ego,
not my bank account." And so, I made one
of my big marketing rules clear, not
clever. And so, you want to take
whatever communication is, look at your
landing pages, look at your ad copy,
look at the words you're saying in your
content, and say, "Does a third grader
understand this?" And the point that
some people try to make as a counter is
like, "Oh, I don't want to talk down to
my audience." No. When you speak in a
more broken down manner,
you help the experts understand it more
easily,
and you help the beginners understand it
for the first time. And so, it's not
that experts are all of a sudden saying,
"Oh, no, I don't believe that." Cuz
listen, we get tons of very big
companies that come to acquisition.com
for investment, and the guys who run
those companies very intelligent. But, I
try to make my videos in a way that
people can understand them because
who do I who do I prove when I use a big
word and then all of a sudden 3/4 of the
audience can't understand it. And if the
point of me making these videos is to
make real business education accessible
for everyone, part of it making it
accessible is making it interesting,
making it fun, and making it
comprehensible, which is just a fancy
word for understandable. And what you
guys don't see behind the scenes is that
I will typically self-edit. And so, I
said distilled earlier in a sense and
then I said broken down for experts is
because I said distilled and I was like,
"I have to use a different word." Broken
down. And then I said comprehensible and
then I said fancy word for
understandable. And so, I try to
constantly catch myself in this, and
it's also made me a significantly more
effective leader. So, if I'm trying to
communicate with my team, I'm not trying
to say big words. I don't want to
impress them, I want to change what they
do. And so, I I've taken this to such an
extreme that with my books, I just use
little little stick figures, right? I
have these little drawings. It's like,
"Oh, look, here's a guy who's walking on
a path. Look, little apple, orange, big
dollar sign, little dollar sign, right?"
We try to make this as simple as
possible so that people can understand
what's actually going on. Because if you
can explain it to a third grader, and
this is Richard Feynman who said this,
this is famous physicist, he said, "If
you can explain it to a third grader,
then you understand it. If you can't,
you don't, and you need to understand it
better so that you can break it down."
And so, the broader the audience, the
broader the analogy, and the simpler the
language.
And so, I'll give you an example. One
element is the grade language of the
words you use. The second is what
visuals or stories you use to depict
them. And so, if I'm talking to
mechanics, I might use an analogy where
I relate something they understand,
cars, to something they might not
understand, a business, right? If I
wanted to teach a specific concept. If I
was talking to the same uh I was trying
to teach the same concept, but I was
teaching it to realtors, then I would
probably use a house analogy. If I was
teaching it to baseball people, I would
probably use a baseball analogy, right?
And so, if you have a narrow down
audience, you will increase
comprehension by using analogies that
they all understand. If you're talking
to a broader audience, then you need to
have a broader slice of the market,
probably a more human experience that
all of them have. So, if I'm talking to
everyone, I might talk about food. I
might talk about sleep. I might talk
about driving, right? Cuz most people do
that, assuming I'm not talking to
children. And so, you have to match the
analogy to the history of learning from
the people that you're trying to
communicate to.
And this is what takes your marketing
and your advertising and puts it on
steroids. And to put this to the test,
this is something you can do right now.
Look at whatever emails you send,
run them through a reading grading level
app,
keep working on it until it's below
fifth grade minimum, third grade if
you're awesome,
and then send it. I did this to our
email follow-ups and had a 50% increase
in conversion. I didn't change anything
about what I said, but I saw that as I
got 50% more people to understand.
Because the goal here is to decrease the
friction of comprehension. So, if we
think about the elements of value,
speed, ease, time delay, these elements
are all impacted by complexity. And so,
something complex takes longer to
understand. It takes more effort, right?
And so, and it it's harder, right? And
so, instead what we want to do is say,
"Okay, how do I make it easy and
faster?" Okay, well, then I'll just
speak in a way that everyone
understands. The next massive growth
lever is proof over promise, all right?
And so, what this means is that in my
earlier days, I would spend so much time
on my promise, right? And
I wrote a whole book on promises, which
is basically offers, right? And I would
obsess about the offer. But
and the offer is super important, but
the only thing that's more important is
proof. All right, so let me give you two
hypothetical examples. Let's say that
you've got business one that's selling
thing one and business two that's
selling thing two. Well, let's say they
still compete for more or less the same
audience. And business two says, "We'll
do X, we'll do Y, we'll do Z, we'll do
W, and we'll guarantee X, Y, and Z,
right?" And you look at their reviews
and they've got a five-star rating and
they've got one review.
The other company says, "We'll do X."
And they've got 11,382
five stars and they've got a 4.7.
Who do you buy from?
This guy, obviously. But why? This guy
has a better promise because you believe
this guy. And so, you want to have proof
up to your eyeballs. Proof is your
single highest priority as a business
owner or marketer or advertiser or
promoter for your business. It is the
one thing that you prioritize. Before I
enter any new space, launch a new
product, the first thing that I do is
try and get beta users. I work for free
in exchange for testimonials, reviews,
and feedback, and sometimes referrals if
I'm lucky.
But in the beginning, that is the
highest most valuable thing that you can
do. So, people will say things like
never work for free. And you only hear
that from people who don't make that
much money.
If you make a lot of money, you will
know that you spend so much time in the
free phase because getting the product
right is so important, is such high
leverage. And so, the proof process both
makes you convicted because you get the
opportunity of many feedback loops to
make your product better so that you
then can collect the positive feedback
that you can then advertise to get more
people like those customers.
And the most compelling way to advertise
anything is show, don't sell.
And if I just stand here and said
nothing, and I said and I just stated
the facts and told the truth, and I
said,
"I have
11,382
reviews, and our average review is 4.7,
and I make pasta really good."
And then
or
"I have one review from my mama,
and I make
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
pasta, guaranteed."
Which one do you like better?
Obviously, this one. You don't need to
say much more. The proof is the pudding.
The most important part of a message is
the messenger themselves. They're
inextricably linked from the thing
that's being communicated, and this is
what people seem to miss when they're
making content, which is why I'm a big
advocate of do epic stuff first, then
talk about what you did. And if the
stuff that you didn't do is epic, focus
more on the doing epic stuff, not on the
talking about it. And so, I started this
channel uh with a commitment to a vendor
saying, "I'll make three YouTube videos
a week." And I was busy, and I was like,
"I'm just going to get a webcam, and I'm
going to talk to the camera." And that
is how this channel was started. And the
only reason, in my opinion, that people
decided to listen was because I just so
happened to have sold a company for just
under $50 million. And so, because of
that, there was proof
that I was able to deliver on the
promise. Whereas, somebody else might
have a totally beautiful studio and have
all these things, but they just forgot
the one most important thing, which is,
"Why should I listen to you?"
And so, either it's going to have to be
proof that you generated for yourself,
or proof from other people saying that
you helped them achieve that thing.
If any of these growth principles help
you in thinking about your business
differently so that you can scale faster
or you need to send it to your team, it
would mean the world to me if you shared
it. Um, that's my only ask.
And appreciate it. So, the next big
thing is the hook. Now, you're like,
"Okay, I've heard about hooks before."
Not the way that I'm going to talk about
it. All right? So, the hook is greater
than everything. Now, you're like, "Wait
a second. I thought proof was greater
than everything." Well, the proof is
going to be contained in the thing, but
no one's going to see the proof unless
you have a good hook. All right? And so,
the one thing that I think has
consistently been reinforced and it's
just like a greater and greater
percentage of my time is allocated
towards this one part of my advertising
that grows my company the most is I
search for the best hooks. And then I
don't convince myself that I'm more
creative than I think I am and I just
keep using the ones that work. So, think
about it like this. These are the only
four things that you can do to advertise
any business. You can warm outreach, so
reaching out one-on-one to people you
know. Cold outreach, reaching one-on-one
to people you don't know. You can run
paid ads, which is going one-to-many to
people you don't know. Or you can post
content, which is one-to-many to people
you do know.
And in each of these four situations you
can double, triple, 5x the amount of
people who open and respond, who click
and watch your ad, who uh watch your
content all the way to the end. And if
you do something like that and you do
increase the click-through rate by go
from 1% to 5% or 2% to 10%, which
absolutely can happen. When you do that
you in a very real way can 2x, 3x, 4x,
5x your business.
With just that one thing. Remember I
talked about earlier that advertising is
a boom? It's a It's an order of
magnitude change. Well, what other one
thing can you just tweak that then opens
up the flow to the entire business based
on how good the first 5 seconds are? Or
the first 1 second? And so, in thinking
about hooks, I think about both the
visual hook, as in what's happening,
what that people can see, and then
there's the auditory or or verbal hook,
which is what are the actual words that
are being communicated. And
we have right now we reviewed our top
YouTube videos of all time and I have
made a video about 6 months ago saying
what we found, which is our hook formula
is proof,
promise,
plan. And so if you have the opportunity
to
make content, make ads, run cold
outbound, if you can include these, I
can almost guarantee that you will do
better than if you include none of them.
And this is a force multiplier on any
kind of advertising you do. And so when
I think about like all the different
things, all the effort that goes into
advertising a business, if I can just do
one thing and the crazy part about hooks
is they're the shortest part. They're
the shortest part of the whole darn
thing. And this is where David Ogilvy
says, "If you have written your
headline, you've spent 80 cents of your
advertising dollar." The more advanced
the advertiser is that I meet, whether
it's a content creator, somebody who's
on outbound, somebody who makes paid
ads, the more obsessive they are on the
first frame, the first impression that
someone gets because they know, one, it
increases the likelihood that the
person's going to watch the rest of it
and then potentially buy, and then two,
it changes their entire perception of
what follows. So we actually looked at
this uh for speakers at an event,
which was if we change the intro, the
the one to two-minute intro that we had
for a 60-minute talk,
the person's net promoter score, so what
people rated them in terms of how good
they were,
changed massively, even though the
actual presentation was the same. So
simply how we framed the presenter, the
person hadn't got up on stage yet,
changed how everything they did
afterwards was perceived. And so if
there's two minutes that can influence
the score that you get, the customer
satisfaction, the amount of prospects,
the one thing to focus on is nail the
hook. Let me show you the force
multiplication of this.
We just started reviewing uh uh content
on the content team and just doing a
more regular activity of seeing like
what are the things that make uh content
do well.
And there was a video that we're like,
"We think this thing is good." And so,
all we did is we took the same video
that got like 40,000 views. And then we
just chopped out the first 3 seconds
that was kind of like getting into the
into the video before the actual real
hook was delivered. And by snipping
those 3 seconds and then just starting
where the hook really was, it went from
a 40,000 view video to a 780,000
view video. So, you're talking about a
19x improvement. So, I'm talking about,
you know, 1% 2% talking 19x.
That is why obsessing over the hook is
so important. So, the next big growth
lever
that gave us the super fast growth was
more. So, I talk about more,
better,
and new as the three primary strategies
of growth. You either do more of what's
already working, you do what you're
doing to make it work better, or you do
something entirely new. Now, most
entrepreneurs love doing new stuff, and
that's why it's called shiny object
syndrome, and it's a cancer, and you
should get that looked at. But, the very
boring answer is the mundane more. You
have to master more. And it's going
instead of zero to one, which is what
most people love doing. Oh my god, I
finally got it to work. But, actually
doing one to N, which is how do I do is
this thing as many times as humanly
possible without wanting to kill myself.
And so, here's the actual math
explanation of this. More is typically
the highest risk-adjusted return
strategy. All right? And so, what that
means is
if you
can do something and you already know it
works, the likelihood that the next
thing you do works is much smaller. And
so, this is why once you have a control,
meaning you have um a specific landing
page or ad or copy or email that you
know converts, whenever you deviate from
a high-converting advertisement, the
likelihood that the variant is going to
beat it is typically low. And so you
have to try a bunch of variations cuz
all you're doing is messing something up
that actually already works. If you had
one sales guy and he's closing at 30%
well, you could try and obsess to get
him to 35 or 40% and that would be
material. You know, you get a 25% lift
overall 30 to 40% is a 25% improvement.
But you know what would be even cooler?
Just hire three more guys and then you
have a
4x or a 300% improvement. And so it's
like I could get a 25% improvement or I
could get a 300% improvement. And me
trying to change up the sales script
also has a significant shot of me taking
it from 30 down to 20 because it's a
change. And so here's the thing is that
when you change anything, you guarantee
you incur the cost of change, but you do
not guarantee that you get the benefit
of change. And so in each of the core
four methods, you do more outreach,
which is cold or warm. You go from 100
reach outs a day to 200 reach outs a
day. Paid ads, you go from $100 a day to
$200 a day. You go from posting content,
you go from posting once a day to twice
a day, right? Those are how you do more.
And when I talk to the most experienced
advertisers that I know, the most
experienced business people that I know,
the most common thing we talk about is
we kind of laugh in the back room of
like if people just people just don't
know how much more they can do. That's
that's honestly the real that's the
real. Is that when I when I when I have
conversations with small business
owners, they're like, "Hey, I don't
think I can do any more
ads. You know, I'm running I'm I'm
already running a thousand dollars a
day." I'm like, "I mean, dude, there's
businesses that run like two million a
day."
And so you usually have so much more
runway than you think you do. And
sometimes you just need someone ahead of
you to be like, "Dude, you can like 10x
this and nothing's going to change." But
they think because of whatever mental
limitation they have or like, "You've
never spent that much money on a on an
ad before. You've never made that amount
of Is it going to hurt my account?" No,
they want you to make good content. "Is
it going to hurt my ads?" No, they want
you to spend money. "Is it going to Is
it going to hurt my my outreach?" You're
going to people who've never met you
before. So, why would they know that you
sent it to another 100 people, right? Is
that there's this these perceived fears,
but most of the times it's just between
your ears. Tell you guys a quick story
about this. So, when I had my first, I
would say real business, which is my
first location of my first gym,
I had a mentor and he was a really good
local marketer. And so, he had a
strategy for his tanning salons where he
would bring in, I mean, thousands of
customers every single every single
quarter. And what he did was he would
put out flyers. He just put flyers on
cars and then had like a, you know, free
VIP gift card people would come in and
redeem them and he flipped them into
memberships.
And so, I figured, okay, I'll just run
the same play. And so, I did the flyers
and I put 300 flyers out and I waited by
the phone be like, oh my god, I'm going
to get 300 people in here. It's going to
be sick. And what happened? Well, my
phone only rang once from the flyers and
when I picked up the phone, the guy was
like, hey, did you put the flyer on my
car? And I was like, yeah, I did. Like,
what time do I have? And then he cut me
off and he was like, you damaged my
Mercedes. And I was like,
click. And I
I didn't know what to do.
And as soon as I I I I and thankfully he
never called me back cuz I definitely
had didn't have the money to fix any
Mercedes at that time.
Um,
I called
my mentor back up, you know, a week or
two later once it was clear that no one
else was going to call. I said He said,
hey, how did the flyers work out? And I
was like, well, they didn't work out at
all, actually. You know, I was like
taking some attitude with him. He was
like, oh, well, what was your test size?
And he didn't like he didn't take the
bait. He was like, oh, what was your
test size? And I said,
well, what do you mean? He was like,
well, like, what you test with before
you like did the real campaign? And I
was like, oh, why?
I mean, I put 300 out. And he was like,
300? He's like, you can't know anything
with 300. I was like, what do you mean?
He's like, I test with 5,000. He's like,
and then we put out
5,000 a day for 30 days.
And so, I was looking at his results
from 150,000
flyers over 30 days and comparing them
to my results of 300 in a day.
And once I saw that juxtaposition, I was
like,
"Got it. I will never make this mistake
again." It was very embarrassing for me
because I was on the right path, I just
didn't do enough. And so, one of the big
metal lessons of this is that
what presents as volatility is typically
a symptom of low volume.
So, if you're like, "Man, I only get
like, you know, a sale every week or
every other week. It's kind of like, you
know, it's you know, most days I don't
get a sale and then every once in a
while I get one." It only appears
volatile because you're doing so little
per day. But, if I looked at your year
and saw that you closed about, let's
say, 12 customers in that year, you
closed one a month, for example, every
every three or four weeks you get a
customer, well, all I would do is look
at your entire advertising activity for
the year and say, "Okay, if we wanted to
get 12 customers a day, we would have to
do 365 times more advertising than we
currently do. And if we did that on a
daily basis, we would get 12 customers a
day." And so, you just take your total
calendar horizontally and then you flip
it vertically for a day and that is how
much volume is required. And so, most
people just think that it's like, "Oh,
they're They can't be doing more than
like twice as much as me." But, in my
experience, the people who are crushing
it literally are doing a thousand times
more than you. And that's the part that
like, until you sometimes you hear it or
you have someone ahead of you say it, it
doesn't become real for you. And it's
why I make these videos is to try and
like push as much, you know, out of out
of my brain and and history so that you
can just get the story without the scar.
Um,
and that's and that's that's the whole
point. Okay. So, once you're like,
"Okay, I have something that's working,
I should just do way more of that."
Awesome. Well, the next thing, the next
power lever here is word of mouth and
it's not the the that you think. So,
word of mouth, people are familiar with
referrals, you know, customers uh
tell other customers or tell other
prospects that your stuff is good. But,
what a lot of people don't understand is
that negative word of mouth is
significantly stronger and faster than
positive.
And so, Disney did this big study where
they found that it takes 37 tragic
moments to make up for one magic moment.
And versus
there's basically like a 5x versus 37x
on
if someone has a good experience they
tell five people, if someone has a bad
experience they tell like everybody. And
so, a new business owner often will get
customers pretty cheaply.
And then all of a sudden costs start
going up. And part of the reason that
costs go up faster, cuz you can actually
put math to this, which is understanding
the difference between CPM, which is
cost per impression, and if it's like,
why is it M? It's mille, which is French
for thousand, so it costs for a thousand
impressions. Versus CPL, which is cost
per lead, all right? And so, if your
CPMs more or less stay the same, but
your cost per lead has 2x, or 3x, or 4x,
well, if it's not costing you more to
reach those people, then it means that
fewer of them are responding. And if
that's the case, and you're just going
to still relatively warm markets, then
the issue is that instead of having
positive word of mouth working for you,
which should be actively lowering the
amount of cost that it takes to get a
new customer, you have
word of mouth working against you. And
so, people who would otherwise purchase
from you heard something negative and
then choose not to. And so, now all of a
sudden you have to reach three times the
amount of people because two out of the
three people who would have gone and
bought your thing heard it was bad, and
then now you only have one person who's
just heard nothing. And so, over time
the percentage of the audience that's
neutral or hasn't heard of you gets
smaller and smaller and smaller. And so,
it's way harder to grow off of word of
mouth that's positive, but it's really
easy to get crushed on negative word of
mouth. And for whatever reason, no
business owner ever claims that they
have negative word of mouth. But I can
tell you, half of you are below average.
That's a fact. And this is why I
emphasize the proof over promise earlier
on so much because if I'm going to get
negative word of mouth, which I know I
am if I'm starting out, I want to keep
that as concentrated and quiet as
possible. I don't want anybody to know,
right? And so of course I'm not going to
charge them money because the last thing
I want to do is also have their money
when they're upset, right? So it's like,
"Hey, I'm making this trade. You're
going to get stopped. It's probably
going to be not be that good. My only
ask is that you give me feedback, right?
Tell me how I can make this right. Tell
me how I can make it better, right? And
when you ask those types of questions,
you get the types of answers that can
ultimately create more value for the
customer. And then once you get positive
feedback, positive feedback, positive
feedback, now you have something that
people actually want. Then you can need
introduce strangers to it. And of course
you're going to roll into the next
issue, which is, "Okay, how do I keep
that consistent because now it's not me
doing everything. I've got a team." And
we'll get into that. Ah, this is a
really good one. So, the next big growth
lever is steal.
Uh-oh. What am I say What am I going to
say? From
yourself.
So, one of our portfolio companies,
which is very large, hired a new
advertising director.
And that advertising director had came
in with lots of new ideas.
And so the founder, because he wanted to
teach an important lesson to the
advertising director, said, "Sure, let's
do all of your ideas." And so he sat
there, he said the scripts, he he, you
know, he he recorded all these ads, he
took multiple days to do it.
And what ended up happening is that they
ran all the ads and they didn't work.
And so he said, "Hey, crazy idea.
What if we use the same hook that's been
working for 3 years?"
And they used the same hook and the ads
worked.
And so, think about it like this.
Nike on its second year after just do it
wasn't like, "Hey, just do it's kind of
old. Let's switch it up." It's like,
when you find a message that converts,
you keep hammering the message. When you
find the ad hooks and you find the the
the processes that work well for you,
most times you'd be better served just
continuing to reuse it because you will
get bored of it far before your
customers ever do. So, believe it or
not, there's actually math to support
this. So, Sergey Brin and Larry Page, I
can't remember which one of them is like
a brilliant mathematician and actually
was able to prove this ratio out.
And so, when you're stealing from
yourself, you want 70% of all of your
effort to going to basically carbon
copying the thing that works. And this
works across all functions. This works
for a sales script, this works for
product, this works for reinvestment
activities, like this rule works. The
second is adjacent. So, something that's
just like 1° removed, right? So, it's
close to the core of what you normally
do, okay? So, instead of saying
starting school communities is the
fastest way to start an online business,
right? I could say that would be a hook
and it's a hook that worked. I could say
um
one of the fastest ways to start an
online business is to start a school
community, right? That would be a
variation of something that we knew that
those words worked, but it would be
adjacent to it, not the exact carbon
copy, but similar. Now, 10 is that means
that one out of 10 of the things that
you're putting your effort towards, all
right, would be something that's
brand-spanking-new, completely, you
know, all out of left field. And when
you look at your effort in your
business, I can almost guarantee you
that you have this flipped.
And I only say this because I speak from
experience.
Um is that this is what I would do. I
would spend 70% of my time on new crazy
things, new ideas, all the stuff that
excited me, and then 20% I'd be like,
"Oh, yeah,
I'll do something kind of different from
what I was doing before." And then 10%
I'll be like, "Fine, I'll I'll maybe."
And this is this is a maybe. Most times
like, "Oh, I already used that. Used
that hook once. I don't want to use it
again. I don't want to use the same hook
that worked before in another ad."
It's silly. Also, a different version of
this from an advertising perspective of
the 20% is use the exact same hook but
you have a different background. So,
it's a just like a different variation.
So, it's like I could wear a different
shirt, I could have a different setting,
and I could still deliver the same hook,
and to me that would still be kind of a
20% variation. All of your competitors
are copying your stuff and taking what's
working.
When you find something that works, keep
doing it. Deviation from what works is
more likely not to work.
Think about it like this.
If you demolish a building, so let's say
we build a building and it takes us 2
years to build a building, right?
There's our building. Took us 2 years.
Demolishing it might take
5 minutes. Just put a bomb, boom.
Because the place of the bricks and the
steel in that building, every other
potentiality that those bricks could go
to create not a building. But there's
only one placement of that brick and
steel that creates a building. And so
you have unlimited options for
destruction and only one for solution.
And so when you do find something that
works, the likely that when you change
it and you move the brick and you move
the you move the scaffolding, that you
destroy the building is very high.
Something can literally go anywhere
except for the right place. And so you
can have more options and all of them be
wrong. So, once you're done stealing
from yourself, then
let's talk about emotional versus
logical buyers. This is a huge, like,
monstrous increase in business for me.
So,
have you ever heard from from the
marketing world, there's logical and
there's emotional buyers. I had heard it
growing up and I kind of repeated it
over and over again because I hadn't
really thought about it.
I don't actually think that's true. And
so let me explain.
I actually think that there's a
continuum of buyers that people sit on,
and you've got people who require more
information, so they're high info
buyers. Then you've got people who
require less information.
And there's two elements to this. One is
their information requirement, and
secondarily, how much info they have
received. And so you could have a high
information buyer that's further closer
to this little this dollar sign here
that only needs a little bit more
information in order to buy. And then
you have some people that just
generically buy lots of stuff. And
everybody loves those people, of course.
But guess what? Everybody fights over
those people. And so, the thing is is
that the amount of low information
buyers is like this. The amount of high
information buyers is an order of
magnitude or multiple orders of
magnitude greater. Only crazy people buy
immediately. It's very normal for people
to want to have more information before
making a decision.
And so,
when we think about our advertising, the
reason that the direct response
community typically can't grow very
large businesses most of the time is
because they only advertise to these
people. And this pool of buyers is
significantly smaller.
But the reason building a brand, for
example, and investing in an audience is
because you're trying to move them down
this line. Now, when I heard this in the
earlier days of my career, I was like,
"I don't have time for that. I need to
make money." I get it. Sure, in the
beginning you just advertise the the
6-in pots. But when you want to scale,
you have to educate a higher percentage
of the audience because they will
require more to buy.
The way to move people through this is
something that Eugene Schwartz uh
pioneered in his book Breakthrough
Advertising.
And he talks about the five levels of
awareness. So, he has unaware people, so
people have just no idea about anything.
Uh the next is problem aware, so they
have some sort of pain. You have
solution aware.
You have product aware.
And then you have most aware. Okay?
So, those are the five stages. Now, a
customer will basically move in this
direction going from unaware to most
aware. And if you want to go to broader
and broader audiences to get their
attention, the unaware audience you
typically have to go off of broad
curiosity. And so, if you've ever seen
those crazy like ads that are like weird
articles like, you know, Arizona State
blah blah blah has this new blah. Like
they're trying to go after a massive
audience people who have no idea what's
going on. That new, you know, scientific
breakthrough could lead you to buying a
supplement. It could lead you to buying
a weight loss thing. It could lead you
to buying some sort of equipment. It
could lead you to buying insurance. Like
it could go in any direction, but it's
the curiosity that gets them in.
Problem aware would be something to the
extent of like, do you wake up to pee
three times a night? Does it hurt when
you bend over to tie your shoes? Do you
get out of breath when you play with
your kids? Those are going to be problem
aware. Now, they again, that could lead
you to a supplement. That could lead you
to insurance. That could lead you to
whatever, but it's a slightly more aware
person. At least they're problem aware.
Solution aware is that somebody knows of
the potential things that they could buy
and you're helping them select between
them. Product aware is at an even more
micro level. And most aware is typically
your existing customers. So, here is
where you just make offers, right? This
is why the book offers is where I
started because
the people who are here is the tiny
audience here. And so, you just make an
offer to get them to buy. But that only
works for this tiny audience. So, you
will make money quickly doing that, but
you will also cap yourself quickly. In
an effort to figure out, okay, well, how
much should I allocate between these
most aware, less info people and the
maybe problem unaware, high information
people who require more education in
order to make a purchasing decision.
Well, I had one of the most enlightening
conversations I've had in a really long
time with Ben Francis, who's the CEO of
Gymshark. And then he introduced me to
Chris Davis, who's the CMO of New
Balance. And so, we had an awesome
conversation talking about what Chris
had done at New Balance and helped them
just skyrocket their sales. And so, what
they did is that when he took over
30% of their advertising budget was
going to here. It was going to the broad
awareness level storytelling emotional
stuff.
And then 70% was basically geared
towards buying shoes, saying hey go buy
these shoes.
What he did when he took over was that
he flipped them. That he ended up with
70% going to big, high-level pairings,
endorsements, uh specific athletes that
they wanted to recruit that they felt
represented their brand, and only 30% of
their advertising budget went towards
actually telling people that they had
shoes and that they were for sale.
And so
after he made that flip, here's the
crazy part. It took 18 months for them
to see the return on that budget. And so
if you're in a rush, this isn't going to
work. But if you're in a rush, you're
never going to get big anyways. Keeping
this ratio made this concept tactical
for me. And so when I think about my
marketing effort, my marketing dollars,
and most importantly how I measure it,
my marketing impressions, I want to make
sure that 70% or more of the advertising
impressions that someone's going to get
are going to be around the pairings that
I want of me giving something rather
than asking. So when we look at this
ratio, this is actually super well
studied between 70 and 30% here. Because
right now uh
it's actually three and a half to one is
the ratio that has been studied, 3.5 to
one
of give
to ask
to
basically not lose audience. And so if
you look at television for example, and
they've already studied how many
commercials can we jam into the show
before people stop watching. And so they
figured it out that it was
every three and a half minutes of
content they could basically put one
minute of advertising in. If you look at
your Facebook newsfeed, for every three
posts you get when you scroll, you'll
get one ad.
And the platforms that grow the fastest
have a larger percentage of this give
and a smaller percentage of ask. TikTok
for years had zero ads on the platform
and just wanted to grow as virally as
possible and they acquired more users
because they had a give first, give all
the time strategy. And so, the fact that
they settled on this ratio and it has
been corroborated, fancy word for it's
worked in multiple other places, made me
think, "Wow, there's something to this."
And so, this makes this concept of how
do I balance high information buyers,
people that need more brand, people that
need more education prior to purchase
with me making money is that you
basically start with that ratio, add
patience and time, and then it becomes a
snowball that compounds onto itself. And
then you will get to a point in the
future where you were still you're doing
so much more than you could ever
possibly do if you only focused on the
direct response, on the less
information, but you're actually still
digging the well for what you're going
to do next year. And so, basically you
can see when a founder stops running a
business and then the corporate execs
come in because what they do is they
flip the ratio, they basically pull
forward demand from the future, they you
had the the the founder dug the well,
and then they just suck all the water
out of the well, but then they didn't
dig the next well. And so, you're always
going to be ahead of demand. I'll give
you even more tactics if you guys want
more tactics, fine, I'll give you more
tactics. So,
B2B businesses and B2C businesses do
this differently. And this was something
that took me a really long time to
figure out. And so, B2C businesses, so
like business to consumer businesses,
will typically
do these types of pairings in terms of
high information buyers by telling
emotional stories, making associations,
getting endorsements from athletes and
influencers or organizations that
represent the values that they think
resonate with their ideal audience.
And once they do that, they then can
place the product next to those
associations so that they can then pair
them and then the person wants to buy
the product as a consequence.
That is what it looks like in a B2C
business.
But it took me a really long time to
think through, "Well, what does this
look like for a B2B business?"
And so, I break this down into several
tactical things. So, number one is
aspirational outcomes that you have
achieved or the business has helped
facilitate. Secondarily, people like
this person, like your avatar, that you
have helped facilitate. So, just to be
clear, it's stuff that you did, stuff
that you helped other people do.
The third is stuff that you helped them
do,
the prospect themselves, which you can
only facilitate, at least in my opinion,
in two major ways. One is that you give
them free content and education, which
is why I make this stuff, and the second
is that you give them free products and
services, which is just why the books
are free, they're on my site, you can
read them, you can consume them. There's
a scaling road map there, personalized.
All that stuff is free. Because
fundamentally,
it's two degrees of separation if some
person does it. Alex had a big exit, now
he's a big portfolio. Cool, that's two
degrees of separation.
There's other companies in the portfolio
or other businesses who look just like
mine that he helped scale, one degree
separation.
I used this stuff and made more money,
zero degrees of separation. And this is
always going to be stronger than
anything else. But, it'll take longer.
And so, in understanding the difference
between B2C and B2B in terms of what do
I do top of funnel here? How do I
allocate my resources? It means that I'm
spending time putting together the
course in my spare time so that you guys
can go consume it on uh how to make
offers, how to get leads, how to scale
comfort from zero to 100 million. Like,
that's time, that's effort, that's my
team who's behind the camera right now,
that's budget that goes towards that
because I'm not looking for demand
today. I'm looking for those of you who
are going to scale your companies in in
five years hit me up. Let's say
acquisition.com went public tomorrow and
I got asked to for being rude, which I
probably would. And then they put in a
new CEO, and that new CEO says, "I need
to hit quarterly earnings." So, what
would he probably do? He'd probably
switch to lots of direct response, uh
and he'd probably cut down all the
budget on the gives and the books and
all the stuff you're like, "Well,
there's no ROI in a book, like books
don't make any money." It's like, "Yeah,
not today,
but they bring people into our world and
when they do have the next
billion-dollar company, they'll hit us
up first."
And that's the goal. But that guy will
just say, "Well, you know what? Screw
all that. I'm going to recapture all
this marketing spend and effort. We're
going to focus it all on these direct
response ads. Tell people to buy, buy,
buy." And you know what? For a quarter,
it'll work. Maybe two quarters it'll
work. But all of a sudden, it'll start
slowly going down, slowly going down,
slowly going down. And then what
happens? They call the founder back up
and they're like, "Hey, help help help
us fix this." And then the founder's
going to say, "I can't do it in a
quarter.
Like, it's going to take me a year, year
and a half to basically right-size the
ship because you sucked all the wells
dry and I'm going to have to start
digging again." So, the next one is some
of my marketing laws. So, I'm going to
give you a few of them and I'll start
with the first one that you If you've
heard my channel, then you should know
this one. It should be ingrained in your
brain, which is state the facts and tell
the truth. And the reason this is so
important to me is that it forces me as
a advertiser, business person
to change reality.
And so, rather than try and exaggerate,
it makes more sense to put all of the
effort into doing epic stuff and then
telling a truthful story rather than
telling an epic story about something
that was underwhelming. And I think the
vast majority of marketers in marketing
do the second thing. They have something
normal and then they try out try and
tell an exaggerated story of it rather
than having something absolutely insane
and just stating the facts and telling
the truth. And I can tell you that the
second, this one, stating the facts and
telling the truth, is the best long-term
strategy. And so, how do I actionalize
this? All right. So, number one is that
we make the truth more compelling. All
right. We actually change reality. The
second is that we show only what we can
show. And so, I remember I was talking
to you a martial arts guy and he's like,
"There's all these other martial arts
studios, you know, in my area. How do I
stand out?" And I said, "Well, what's
your you know, what's your specialty or
whatever?" And he said, "I'm a double
secret black belt of something." And I
said, "Okay, well, how many double
secret black belts?" He said, "Well,
there's only six in the nation." And I
was like, "Okay, well, do any of them
live in your area?" And he said, "No."
And I was like, "Well, why don't you say
that?" Right? Why don't you say that?
So, every business, if you get narrow
enough, has something that's unique
about it. You might have the best
parking. You might have uh the fastest,
you know, introduction to getting
somebody to sit down. You might have the
most gyms. You know, whatever it is, the
most customers, the most customers at a
certain price point, the most like you
just need to slice the data of the
business to figure out what is unique
about your business. And I remember this
moment in uh Mad Men, which is a uh an
advertising show. It's like an old '50s
show. Well, it's a new show about the
'50s, anyways.
And Don Draper, who's the lead
character, is an advertising guy, um is
pitching a client who's a cigarette
company. And they're trying they're like
the third or fourth in the category.
They're highly commoditized. They're
competing on price, and they're losing.
And so, he asks them to explain how
cigarettes are made. And they kind of
roll their eyes. They're like, "Why is
this important?" He's like, "Okay, well,
first we have the plants, and then we
take" And he keeps going through it.
He's He's like, "And then we, you know,
we let we let it sit out in the sun."
He's like, "What do you mean?" He's
like, "You know, to to to dry out the
leaves." He's like, "So, you toast
them." He's like, "Yeah, we toast them."
He's like,
"It's toasted."
And so, that was a unique part. He just
sliced down and got really narrow about
one particular part of the process and
was able to pull that out and emphasize
it so that people are like, "Oh, this is
different than other things." And the
really important part about this is that
maybe some of the other cigarette
companies also toast it. But they don't
say that they toast it. And so, the
perception is still that it's different
even if it is the same. And so, the best
version of this is finding something
that's truly unique. The second best
version is to just say something that's
unique about something that everyone
else already does, but that your
customers don't know.
And so, the the correlator to that is
say what only you can say. So, you show
what only you can show, and you say what
only you can say. So, the showing part
is going to be like, "Okay, with the
toasting thing, how do we display that
visually?" With the super secret black
belt then, how do we display that? And
you could show the black belt. You could
show you shaking your hands getting the
certification. You could show you
winning some tournament, right? If
you're if you're toasting, you could
show the bed of all the the tobacco
that's getting toasted and the smells
and the wafting through the air,
whatever, right? And then you describe
it in a way that only you can say.
And so, to do this, you get narrower to
be more unique. And so, the thing is is
that you don't need to be the best in
the world. You need to be the best in a
puddle. It's more important that you are
the best than what you are the best of.
I would rather be
from a marketing perspective, not
absolutely. I'd rather have the 10th
biggest company in the world, right?
Than the first biggest company uh in
Indiana. But, from an advertising
perspective, it is more compelling to be
the best.
And I'll tell you a story that I haven't
told.
Um
John Rockefeller,
when he uh was early on in his oil
empire,
bid to buy the biggest oil refinery in
Cincinnati.
And he was the second biggest.
And he ended up overpaying for the
business. And the business owner of the
oil refinery laughed at him and kind of
laughed his way to the bank. He's like,
"You completely overpaid for this
thing." And so, then what John D.
Rockefeller did, after he bought the
second the the first biggest and he
already had the second biggest, is that
he then was able to say he was the
biggest. And then in the next 30 days,
he did over 20 M&A deals in the next 30
days to consolidate the entire rest of
the market because he became the
gorilla.
And so, he was willing to overpay for
the asset to get the story.
The difference in value between what he
should have paid for those 20 deals and
what he was able to pay by strong-arming
those smaller competitors because he was
now the gorilla more than made up for
what he minorly overpaid or maybe even
majorly overpaid for the one company
that he bought. And when he recounts the
story, when he tells the story again, he
talks about how that competitor didn't
see the bigger picture.
And that was always it was such a I
remember reading it in the in the
letters that he wrote to his son and
thinking to myself,
that is powerful. He was willing to
overpay for the story. He saw it as an
investment in his brand, in his
reputation. And so the guy who sold it
just saw it as him overpaying for a
product, but he wasn't appropriately
valuing how much true brand value that
would give Rockefeller as a result. The
next big growth lever is all about the
list, right? So, when I talk about the
list, people immediately think that I'm
talking about email list, direct mail
list, and sometimes that's true. But
I'll give you a hypothetical example.
So, let's say I am selling winter coats.
And I advertise an amazing offer on some
killer coats
that people love, they look amazing, and
nothing comes back. Well,
what could have happened? Well, if I
showed my advertisement to people who
live in South Florida,
the likely that they buy my very
expensive, really heavy, and hot winter
coats is very low. It has nothing to do
with my offer, nothing to do with ad
creative, nothing to do with my pricing,
nothing to do with anything. It's just
the wrong people are seeing it. And so
many smaller businesses
think that marketing doesn't work, when
in reality they were showing it to the
wrong people. And so the first thing
that you have to get right in marketing
is targeting the correct audience. And
so this is different by method of
advertising. And so if we pull up our
core four here, you want to reach out to
people that you know are suffering from
the problem that you solve or have a
high likelihood of suffering from the
problem that you solve. And the narrower
the problem, the smaller the list.
From a paid ads perspective, this is
where the targeting by platform gets
more important. And this is why some ad
platforms tend to be more profitable
than others because what makes an
advertising platform successful is how
well targeted it is. In fact, Facebook
was so good that they had to roll it
back because of privacy laws, but it was
so effective at targeting people that
people complained cuz it was so good. It
felt creepy. Posting content, this is
where the algorithm itself, based on
This is what's crazy. What you look like
and how you talk and what you say will
impact what the AI serves your content
to. The same works with paid ads. And
so, if I want to get more women to buy a
product, guess who I'm not going to have
in the ad? Me. Because this is not what
attracts lots of ladies, right? This is
just usually a bunch of entrepreneurs
who tend
to have beards and like fitness or
whatever else, right? But like my
audience is like 89% male. And sure, for
for my 11% females, keep rocking, I
appreciate you. Um but by and large, I
have a male-driven audience. Now, maybe
it's because I talk about money, but
there's tons of female entrepreneurs who
talk about money and don't have
predominantly male audiences. And so,
it's just that my way of saying things
and or the algorithm just tends to
display it to dudes. And so, one of the
easiest ways to make sure that you're
displaying your ads to the right avatar
is make sure that the person in the ad
looks like the avatar. And I'll tell you
a funny story. So, when I was running
the Gym Launch 1.0 version, which is
where we used to fly out to gyms and do
the turnarounds,
I found out that when I put the thank
you page, this is before automated
schedulers even existed. So, it's kind
of wild. All right. Um I remember when I
got my first automated schedule put on
the thank you page, I thought I had like
I'd I'd cured cancer. I was like, this
is the coolest thing ever. People can
automatically book. Like I don't have to
call them and work the lead.
Um and so anyways, the thank you page
that I set up uh was just like, "Hey,
text this number." And then the second
version of the thank you page was, "Hey,
my name's Alex. I'm going to be the one
calling you." So, I put a picture of me
and I said, "I'm going to be calling you
from this number." So, I tried to put
some visual to it.
Then when I put Leila's picture on the
thank you page and said, "Leila's going
to be the one contacting you." What do
you know? Our response rates went
through the roof. People were
immediately responsive. They were
showing up to appointments. They were oh
yeah, sure. I can make 5:00. For me
they're like oh no, I don't give a
right. And so if you want to attract a
certain avatar, try to make sure that
what is in your content, how you talk
matches the way they talk because
fundamentally all marketing works as
long as you get the targeting right.
It's like think about this way. If you
walked into a room, this is how I like
to visualize marketing because people
people over complicate it. If I walked
into a room and I got on stage and there
was a thousand people in the room. If
those thousand people were my ideal
customers, then even if I had just like
a really mediocre offer and
something that they like kind of wanted,
I would get some response. Now it might
not be efficient. It might not get me
the return I want, so I might lose
money, but I might I would probably make
something, right? I would get some
clicks. I would get some leads, right?
And so it would allow me to start the
feedback loop so I can improve. But if
nothing is coming through, it's
typically because the wrong people are
seeing it. And so one of the highest
leverage ways of getting more from
advertising is just making sure the
right people are seeing it.
Which is a perfect transition into the
next one, which is how do you know that
you've mastered something? Which is that
masters have more ways to win. Now, what
does that actually mean?
They understand the many different ways
that you can measure progress. So if you
were to talk to an HR professional,
okay? And you ask them what do you do? A
lot of times they're going to give you a
couple vague answers. They're like, you
know, I'll payroll and I'll
I'll make sure that people get in their
benefits and whatever.
But when you talk to someone who's a
master at this and I remember the first
time I had somebody who completely
improved my understanding of talent and
acquisition and recruiting. Um in the
interview, the candidate said, oh,
well what's your time to fill? And I was
like, what do you mean? She's like, well
the average time to fill a role. I was
like, I don't know. She's like, oh,
well, what's your what's your two-sided
fit? I was like,
I don't know what you mean.
And so, she's like, okay, what's your
cost to acquire talent? I was like,
I don't know. And so, she had all of
these different metrics that she was
using to measure, which completely made
sense to me. Like, I have cost to
acquire a customer, I should have cost
to acquire talent. I should have, you
know, what's my cash conversion cycle?
How quickly do I get my first sale? How
quickly do I fill a role? And then, in
terms of like customer satisfaction,
it's basically employee satisfaction of
how likely is it that the manager and
the employee both say at day 90 that
this is a 10 out of 10 fit. And so, when
I started looking at that, I was like,
oh, wow, there's a total there's a whole
'nother level of understanding this that
I I had no idea about. Because masters
have a higher quality and quantity of
metrics that they use to measure
progress. And so, if I am trying to fix
this function, I have nothing to know
how well I'm doing. And so, a beginner
will try to advertise, or will try to
sell, and they will have binary
outcomes. They'll just say, I didn't
sell, or I did sell, or I got leads, or
I didn't get leads. But, there are so
many nuanced steps between that. And
when you have the milestones, the
progress markers, it allows you to fix
things so you can keep moving the buck
along until you get the outcome. And so,
I'll tell you a story about this.
So, when I was starting outbound, way
back in the day,
I it was a new channel for us, and I'd
never done it. And about 90 days, or or
or 4 months in, my executive team kind
of did like an intervention. So, they
came together, and it's like I was
getting like a drug rehab, right? They
were like, we think this is a problem.
We think this is a shiny object. We
think you're you're distracted, and we
should double down on what works. I was
like, how dare you use my words against
me, right? And the thing is is that
strategically, I knew we needed to have
a second acquisition channel for us to
sell the business. And so, I was like,
no, it's because they could only see
that we'd only done one sale in four
months and 100% of my time was going
towards this. But what they didn't see
was all the progress that we were
making. And so I had higher degrees of
mastery in this. Now, to be fair, it was
just because I had learned it along the
way, but when it started it was like,
"Okay, well, we have to get a list. So,
where do we get the list?" So, we looked
at you know, we bought a bunch of
different lists. A lot of different
lists didn't work. One of them did.
We're like, "Okay, this is a good
provider." And then we start, you know,
like, "Oh, we got to enrich the data."
So, we start learning how to enrich the
data. Then we we started calling them,
but then no one's picking up. And then
we had to learn how call wrapping works.
So, we get local numbers. Then all of a
sudden people start picking up and then
start hanging up on us. So, then we had
to fix the the hook in the script. And
then we fixed the hook in the script,
people would make it a minute, but then
they'd hang up on us. So, then we got we
fixed the hook, and then we fixed the
offer, and then people would then go to
the second call, but then they weren't
showing up for the second call. And so,
it's like, we have to just keep moving
the buck along the way. But if you
looked at it two months in, it's like,
you know, a heart surgery looks like
murder to somebody from the outside who
doesn't understand the milestones. And
so, as you master something, if you
don't know why something's not working,
look closer. Look for the smaller
attributes that you can actually zoom in
on and say, "Okay, well,
we'll get a sale eventually if we just
keep moving in this direction." And so,
look for directional correctness rather
than binary. And so, this is a perfect
example of masters have more leading
indicators to success than beginners do.
Beginners typically look at purely the
lagging They just say churn is up. They
sales are down. Revenue's down. Cash
collection's down. Those are all lagging
indicators. You can't If I looked at you
and said, "Increase revenue." You can't
do anything. If I said, "Decrease
churn." You can't do anything with that.
You would then have to do something
else, and then the result would be a
decrease in churn. The result would be
more revenue. The result would be more
sales. And so, we have to do we have to
identify what all those steps are that
are high correlates or increase the
likelihood that ultimate outcome occurs.
And if you liked these growth
principles, you're absolutely going to
love the 13 years of marketing lessons
that I've learned. It's one of my top
videos. Enjoy it.